hey Vsauce Michael here there is an art
museum on the moon
supposedly we can't be sure until we go
back and check but as the story goes in
1969 Fred wall Tower from Bell
Laboratories and sculptor Forrest Myers
convinced an engineer working on the
Apollo 12 lunar lander to hide a
itsy-bitsy roughly 2 by 1 centimeter
ceramic tile within the gold blankets
wrapped around parts of the spacecraft
that would be left on the moon and
etched onto that ship or artworks by
famous artists according to everyone
involved the plan worked and when the
Apollo 12 team left the moon the wafer
was still there now two days later Myers
told the New York Times what they had
done and this image of the wafer was
published it contains a rauschenberg
straight line a Oldenburg drawing of
Mickey Mouse pretty cool and the story
is likely to be true if confirmed that
would make this wafer the first and
currently only art museum on the moon
but the thumb is covering something in
fact it's covering Andy Warhol's
submission
why well according to Warhol all he did
was innocently etch his initials on the
chip he stylized them like this
he drew a somewhat funny W for Warhol
and then put a line right across here to
make this bit look like an a that's it
it's just his initials here's an
unobscured view of a replica that's on
the moon right now I however am on earth
right now in North America and this is a
map of North America which is cool
because if you are in the place you have
a map of well mathematically there will
always be some point on your map that is
directly above the place in the real
world it represents always it doesn't
matter how you hold the map it can be
rotated flipped even twisted folded or
crumbled it is guaranteed by brower's
fixed point theorem a fixed point is
anything that goes nowhere
after a transformation Brouwer's theorem
tells us that it is impossible to
completely mix up a set of points if
they are bounded without holes and
transformed continuously with no cutting
or gluing without bounds every point can
be mapped somewhere new around holes
every point can be mapped somewhere new
and if you cut or glue every point can
be mapped somewhere new but otherwise
mixing will always fail somewhere a
transformation is continuous if as the
distance between any two points reaches
zero in the before state it also
approaches zero in the after State
each square of this checkerboard is
filled with point like pixels of a
unique color as we transform it
let's have pixels still within the
square they began in glow okay as you
can see no matter how you resize or
manipulate the checkerboard it will
always glow somewhere you cannot get
every pixel to be simultaneously outside
of its original square unless you cut or
move the whole shape outside of the
space that used to fill here's a
question do you think you can completely
mix up coffee in a mug by stirring well
of course you can not stirring coffee is
a continuous transformation of the
coffee and everything stays within the
same space so brower's fixed-point
theorem applies no matter how well you
try to stir there will always be after
the liquid has settled at least one
point that you stirred right back to
where it was before a fixed point to be
sure coffee isn't made out of points
it's made out of molecules but they're
quite tiny and very numerous so within a
degree of error it'll pretty much hold
fixed points
don't just frustrate your ability to
fully mix things they can also suck you
toward them they can be attractive like
the number nine try this think of a
number with more than one digit and then
add up its digits now subtract that sum
from the original number to get a new
number if you do this over and over and
over again until you're left with a
single-digit number you will always end
up with nine
every time also notice that any number
with two or more digits minus the sum of
its digits becomes divisible by nine
right away what's going on here well
there's nothing mystical about nine misc
in general instead it's just a
consequence of how we write numbers
numbers can be written in all sorts of
ways but the most common base ten
positional notation makes the nine trick
work
in this system a number like twenty five
doesn't mean two and five
it means ten twos and one five that's
twenty-five so subtracting out just the
positional digits of a number removes
one member from each group the digit you
have one of completely disappears the
digit you have ten of goes down to nine
copies the digit you have 100 of goes
down to 99 copies and so on so the whole
thing becomes a multiple of nine
attractive fixed points also play a
starring role in a famous method for
calculating square roots it's called the
babylonian method the number you want to
find the square root of is called the
radicand and it's square root is some
number that is equal to the radicand
divided by itself okay now step one of
this method is guess if your guess is
lower than the actual answer the
radicand divided by your guests will be
larger than the answer and vice-versa
the true answer will always be somewhere
in between those two values so after you
guess take both values and find their
average it'll be a point in between and
now use this value as your guests and
keep going
you will converge towards the true
square root at a pretty nice speed the
number of correct digits in your
approximation will roughly double after
every iteration
that's pretty cool but let's talk about
infinity specifically Aleph numbers they
describe sizes of well ordered
infinities the smallest is aleph-null
equal to the quantity of integers that
there are but there are literally larger
infinities than that in order of
increasing size they are Aleph 1 a love
- Aleph 3 and so on each one is infinite
but refers to a greater number of things
than the infinity before if you tried to
pair up aleph-null things with Aleph 1
things you'd literally run out of
aleph-null things first even though it's
endless you can hear more about Aleph
numbers in this video of mine but here's
the thing there happens to be an Aleph
fixed point notice that the subscript of
each Aleph is equal to the number of
infinities less than it there are none
less than Aleph null one less than Aleph
1 2 less than a love 2 and so on each
next Aleph number is monstrously bigger
than the last but only adds one to the
growing list of Olives clearly these
rates are so different they'll never
meet up but they do take a look at this
number Aleph Aleph Aleph alfalfa a load
rule and so on an endless cascade of
Olives
how many infinities are smaller than
this number well look at its subscript
it's well it's an endless cascade of a
lafe's just like the number itself this
is an Aleph fixed point and infinity so
large it is equal to the number of
infinities smaller than itself
that's cool but probably my favorite
fixed point related thing is the force
of Coulomb theorem
it states that at any given moment there
must be at least one pair of points on
Earth's surface that are diametrically
opposite one another but nonetheless
have the same temperature and
atmospheric pressure diametrically
opposite points on a sphere are called
Antipodes and as I've discussed before
if you place a piece of bread on the
ground somewhere on earth and another
one on that points antipode well you've
made yourself an earth sandwich there
are sites that help you locate such
opposite points on land but at this
moment in history you'll notice that
most points on land are antipodal to
water which makes sense the Earth's
surface is mainly covered with water but
even though we know that we don't always
appreciate just how gigantic the Pacific
Ocean is maybe because maps tend to cut
right along at dividing its power but
take a look at this this is the Atlantic
Ocean all right this is the Pacific
Ocean it's really more of a water
hemisphere the Pacific Ocean is so large
in fact it contains its own Antipodes
meaning there are places in the Pacific
Ocean where you could float and know
that even if you dug a hole straight
down through the center of the earth and
emerged on the other side you would
still be in the Pacific Ocean ok anyway
back to borsa Coulomb to see how it
works let's imagine two thermometers on
opposite sides of the earth a and B the
temperatures they record will probably
be different but if we swap their
locations always keeping them at all
times on opposite sides of the planet
their temperature readings will just
flip in order to swap well the readings
are going to have to cross at least once
no matter how we swap these always and
typical thermometers a crisscross will
have to
happen at least one somewhere moreover
these fixed points aren't just peppered
around the globe willy-nilly
a continuous unbroken band of them must
separate A's region from bees why well
because if there wasn't such a wall that
would mean there'd be a way to swap them
without their readings having to ever
meet which we know can't happen okay
next let's pick a pair of antipodal
points on this band and measure
atmospheric pressure at both if they're
the same hey that's pretty good
our job is done but if they're not we
can just swap the barometers along the
band like with temperature the pressures
they measure swap so somewhere they will
have to have the same value even though
weather is chaotic and always changing
and even though the other side of the
world is very very far away there must
always be at least two places on
opposite ends of the earth where the
temperature and the pressure are the
same this is true by the way for any two
variables that vary continuously across
Earth's surface for is often called a
cosmic number why well because try this
name any number in English really any at
all positive negative rational complex
uninteresting surreal infinite doesn't
matter now count the number of letters
in its name this gives you a new number
count the number of letters in its name
and keep going eventually every time
every single time you will wind up at
four where you will be stuck looping
forever side note if doing something
over and over again doesn't produce a
different result than just doing it once
the procedure is called ident
meaning same power taking the absolute
value of a number is an ID impotent Act
doing it once or doing it a million
times gives the same result
pushing an elevator call button is
identity' new on spill come to you
pushing it again and again and again and
again
doesn't make it arrive faster or
differently anyway we get stuck at four
because it's the only number in the
English language spelled with the same
number of letters as the quantity it
represents about four years ago
reddit user protocol seven showed that
there are no other endless loops except
for and that while negative 15 and
negative 17 both contain their absolute
value worth of letters which makes them
special to be sure they obviously aren't
spelled with a negative number of
letters for is for JUnit there's no
escape a path to it is forced Oh Fork
it's even on my forearm well I look
forward to seeing you again soon
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
I have some exciting news if you are a
parent with young children or if you are
a young child yourself I have a video
over on sesame studios that you should
check out sesame studios is from the
creators of Sesame Street and it's a
great new channel full of really awesome
videos for young people so go check that
channel out subscribe if your kids use a
different account subscribe through that
account or whatever you have to do to
get stuff from sesame studios it's great
Kevin and Jake already have videos over
there go watch mine check that out and
as always thanks for watching
[Music]